[Musique]
smasher comme les grands noms de la nba
sauter sur un muret faire l'acrobate
odom barque offre aucune limite
ouvert depuis seulement une semaine le
premier par 4 en polynésie been fait
déjà des adeptes chez des amis à votre
tour et je trouve que c'est bien tu peux
sauter tu peux faire des saltos et tu
peux faire plein de trucs on attendait
ensemble comme ça parce qu'il fallait
aller dans le 92 de nous cette première
nuit d' à côté de notre club donc
forcément ça attire les jeunes le club
ça nous attire nous la cua autre peut
faire pas mal de choses là des éléments
pour l'apa dans le club
donc ça me permet pour nous de nous
perfectionner amateurs et professionnels
se côtoient dans cet espace de 1500
mètres carrés équipée d'une trentaine de
trampoline la mise en place a pris deux
mois pour pouvoir proposer différentes
activités
le prisonnier donnent une fausse accuse
un concept découvert aux états unis par
le responsable
c'était une expérience j'ai testé par
hasard l'activité on vient jump et entre
potes en famille physiquement ça demande
un minimum de
d'entraînement ou un minimum de physique
donc effectivement je sens que les gens
s'attendaient pas à ce que soit aussi
dur mais sont très contents et
reviennent du mardi au dimanche les
jumper sont attendus dont la reine
comptait 12 euros pour pouvoir se
défouler pendant une heure le temple du
rebond propose également des formules
anniversaire pour les enfants
[Musique]